i've been hearing you talk
quite a bit about uh string theory
landscape and the swamp land
what the heck are those two concepts
okay very good question so let's go back
to what i was describing about fine man
yes feinman was trying to do these
diagrams for graviton
and electrons and all that he found that
he's getting infinities he cannot
resolve
okay the natural conclusion is that
field theories and gravity and quantum
theory don't go together
and you cannot have it so in other words
field theories
and gravity are inconsistent with
quantum mechanics period
string theory came up with
examples but didn't address the question
more broadly that
is it true that every field theory can
be coupled to gravity in a quantum
mechanical way
it turns out that feminine was
essentially right
almost all particle physics theory is no
matter what you add to it
when you put gravity in it doesn't work
only
rare exceptions work so string theory
are those rare exceptions
so therefore the general principle that
feynman found was correct
quantum field theory and gravity and
quantum mechanics don't go together
except for jules exceptional cases there
are exceptional cases
okay the the total vastness of quantum
field theories that are there
we called the set of quantum field
theories
possible things which ones can be
consistently coupled to gravity
we call that subspace the landscape
the rest of them we call the swampland
it doesn't mean they are bad quantum
field theories they are perfectly fine
but when you couple them to gravity they
don't make sense unfortunately
and it turns out that the the ratio of
them the number of theories which are
consistent with gravity
to the ones which without the ratio of
the area of the landscape
to the swamp land in other words is
measure zero
and so the swamp land is infinitely
large the swampland is infinitely large
so let me give you one example
take a theory in four dimension with
matter
with maximum amount of super symmetry
can you get
it turns out a theory in four dimension
with maximum amount of supersymmetry
is characterized just with one thing a
group what we call the gauge group
once you pick a group you have to find
your theory
okay so does every group make sense yeah
as far as quantum field theory every
group makes sense there are infinitely
many groups there are infinitely many
quantum field theories
but it turns out their only finite
number of them
which are consistent with gravity out of
that same list
so you can take any group but only find
number of them the ones whose what we
call the rank of the group
the ones whose rank is less than 23.
quant bigger than rank 23 belongs to the
swampland they're infinitely many of
them
they're beautiful field theories but not
when you include gravity
so so then this becomes a hopeful thing
so in other words
in our universe we have gravity
therefore we are part of that dual
subset
now is this joule subset small or large
yeah it turns out that subset is
humongous but we believe still finite
the set of possibilities is infinite but
the set of
consistent ones i mean the set of
quantum figures are infinite
but the consistent ones are finite but
humongous
the fact that they're humongous is the
problem we are facing in string theory
because we do not know
which one of these possibilities the
universe we live in
if we knew we could make more specific
predictions about our universe we don't
know
and that is one of the challenges with
string theory which point on the
landscape which corner of this landscape
do we live in we don't know so what do
we do
well there are there are principles that
are beginning to emerge
so i will give you one example of it you
look at the patterns of what you're
getting
in terms of these good ones the ones
which are in the landscape compared to
the ones which are not
you find certain patterns i'll give you
one pattern
you find in the all the ones that you
get from string theory
gravitational force is always there but
it's
always always the weakest force
however you could easily imagine field
theories
for which gravity is not the weakest
force for example
take our universe if you take a mass of
the electron
if you increase the mass of electron by
huge factor
the gravitational attraction of the
electrons will be bigger than the
electric repulsion between two electrons
and the gravity will be stronger that's
all
it happens that's not the case in our
universe because electron is very tiny
in mass compared to that
just like our universe gravity is the
weakest force we find in all
these other ones which are part of the
good ones
the gravity is the weakest force this is
called the weak gravity conjecture we
conjectured that
all the points in the landscape have
this property
our universe being just an example of it
so there are these qualitative features
that we are beginning to see
but how do we argue for this just by
looking patterns just by looking string
theory as this
no that's not enough we need more
more reason more better reasoning and it
turns out there is the reasoning for
this turns out to be studying black
holes
ideas of black holes turn out to put
certain restrictions
of what a good quantum filter should be
it turns out
using black hole and the fact that the
black holes evaporate
the fact that the black holes evaporate
gives you a way
to to check the relation between the
mass and the charge of elementary
particle because what you can do
you can take a charged particle and
throw it into a charged black hole
and wait it to evaporate and by the
looking at the properties of evaporation
you find that
if it cannot evaporate particles whose
mass is less than their charge
then it will never evaporate you'll be
stuck and so the possibility of a black
hole evaporation forces you to have
particles
whose mass is sufficiently small so that
the gravity is weaker
so you connect this fact to the other
fact so we begin to find
different facts that reinforce each
other so different
parts of the physics reinforce each
other and once they all
kind of come together you believe that
you're getting the principle correct so
weak gravity conjecture is one of the
principles we believe in
as a necessity of these conditions so
these are the predictions
string they are making is that enough
well it's qualitative
it's a semi-quantity it's just that mass
of the electron should be less than some
number
but that number is if i call that number
one
the mass of the electron turns out to be
10 to the minus 20 actually so it's much
less than one it's not
one but on the other hand there's
a similar reasoning for a big black hole
in our universe
and if that evaporation should take
place gives you another restriction
tells you the mass of the electron
is bigger than 10 to the is now in this
case bigger than something
it shows bigger than 10 to the minus 30
in the planck unit so
you find aha the mass of the electron
should be less than 1 but bigger than 10
to the minus 30.
in our universe the mass of the
electrons tends to minus 20.
okay now this kind of you could call
postdiction but i would say
it follows from principles that we now
understand from string theory
first principle so we are making
beginning to make
these kinds of predictions which are
very much
connected to aspects of particle physics
that we didn't think
are related to gravity we thought just
take any electron mass you want
what's the problem it has a problem with
gravity and so that conjecture
has also a happy consequence that it
explains that our universe
like why the heck is gravity so weak is
a force
uh and that's not only an accident but
almost a necessity
if these forces are to coexist
effectively
exactly so that's that's that's the
reinforcement of
of of what we know in our universe but
we are finding that
as a general principle so we want to
know what aspects of our universe
universe is forced on us like the weak
gravity conjecture and other aspects do
we under how much of them
do we understand can we have particles
lighter than neutrinos or maybe that's
not possible
you see the neutrino mass it turns out
to be related to dark energy
in a mysterious way naively there's no
relation between dark energy and a mass
of a particle
we have found arguments from within the
swampland kind of ideas
why it has to be related and so
so they're beginning to be these
connections between graph consistency of
quantum gravity
and aspects of our universe gradually
being
sharpened but we are still far from a
precise quantitative prediction like
we have to have such and such but that's
the hope that we are going in that
direction
you